they're helping us pitch our tank and
it's our first time building out this
tent is so chillaxing and relaxing you
look so hot cooking I think it's pretty
hot when you film - it's a little enough
Bart's gonna let me use I always get so
nervous
[Applause]
how are you about to do TIFF but to go
off-roading what are you about to do sir
about to go off-roading
we're good about to do KC voting
oh here's the trail oh man I wish I was
there you would have a blast this winter
drive after like made away or something
- all right you're in the driver's seat
now you're crazy hot brother for a
first-timer oh my god you know me
no wonder safety nope loco
yeah oh okay Oh freaking flood first
yeah - you're on talk at the spirit
porphyrin heard Wow oh my good
that was it this so cool good drop like
20 degrees it feels like huh am I alone
look at Priscilla I'm so cool how do you
do it fixing this because I see that
there's mosquitoes coming out and
there's this tiny little patch of my
ankle sticking out and I don't want to
be bitten Hey
bitten oh yeah not Vincent mitten yeah
so Gigi says that I always pronounced at
ease in a lot of words i huntington and
mittens and bitten but now I'm learning
how to say it with the D I guess like
these now didn't I even it's just not
they're just not there she's silent
bitten now I gotta teach you how to say
fix in there yeah do you say that yeah
she died her is so weird that I used to
say fixing it well sometimes I just say
it cuz I'm joking no you really Chuck
our chunk chunk so on I know the word is
Chuck but I say tongue
I feel like a crazy person in this to
California world everyone in Texas knows
that the slang for throwing something
away really hard is chunk at least
there's two versions at least because I
knew what chuck was to and when I came
over here tsch heard me say chunk and
she was like what are you talking about
and I said chunk isin throwing something
really far away like really hard
chunk she said you mean Chuck and I
thought you were crazy until I went to
Texas and then I saw your brother made
like some video for school or something
and it said like chunk it or something
like that and I'm like wait so it is a
Texas thing bless you and then I was
like oh I guess you're not crazy I'm
actually a over the years of being in LA
no like roughly seven years I've
modified my speech now and my English to
accommodate LA talk now my mittens are
so hard mittens
not the only one you cold
just a little I couldn't tell are you
not cold Bart oh my god he's not wearing
anything I am done I am calm now wear
something share yours a stream to wash
your hands yeah you're about to get
warmed up I feel like you're about to
say whatever you're first getting ready
to do I like walk around with 5,000
pesos with my core it was 2005 we can do
the whole house me it's already cut I
already cut it I just wanted to make a
little bit of our ventilation all right
what are you doing Eddie
so this is how you make firewood from
the wild fire within the wild yeah
except one who take your eyes and your
wood uh-huh and your chocolate like what
easy so this is what happens when you
have tinder but you don't have a fire
you get two rocks right this is easy for
the other thing in your hand another
Rock hey just easy just have to hit it
on a right angle I have 500 so I'll show
you guys right now how it works like
that it's pretty easy yeah let's go
this is capping one too deep so Nadine
sir that your uncle's kabob totally
hungry kabobs I'm already smelling I've
never had this foot box
I already know that they gonna know my I
don't really know how to become
I think since you guys haven't really
tried real kebab my kebab to me tasting
and you guys know that all right kebabs
are really good though
wait till you guys have either these and
then the way to you guys looks I'm just
gonna try like the stuff I feel so I
haven't had anything come near that
always ask me like what's somebody I
really there's nothing as I can explain
that similar visor or client
I'll tell them Mike obviously Korean
food Chinese food Japanese food are
different but they share a similar
palette of rice soy sauce to the clothes
very similar yeah Easton Afghan there's
gotta be like a distant cousin like
Chinese and Thai food are two different
things but they're very similar mo John
what would you compare a vehicle to like
another culture food to be honest with
you I never tastes like nothing
compressor right only one time I was in
catch me
and also Parker just a kiss on antenna
has a trap yeah military surgeon who's
back I understand
woohoo with what wasn't call havoc on
Bora for life cyclic provided hazard
creams it's everywhere
all right learn from a pro Nadine we had
a head count originally for this camping
trip yurga
25 billing but only 12 people showed up
so we have double the amount of food for
the amount of people that are here so we
have a lot of food there's only 12 of us
to eat and drink everything Cheers
oh man oh wow
I want to try that buy that presents
okay don't write this okay this is the
bisphosphate
that's the best part grab that
[Music]
are you doing right now chopping wood so
everyone have a go fire he's looking at
fire on that fire right there why it
looks a little bleak that's your
handiwork yeah I stole it because it's
because of peace wow this is so much fun
oh that's good beer oh for sure
[Music]
I can be locked me out cuz there's bugs
coming in they're attracted to light Oh
ladybug is still here I know it's been
chilling in our tent for the whole day
layaway ladybug but no it is sly way and
then I did this to make sure it flew it
oh oh we're gonna have guests actually
having a sleepover with Jerome Priscilla
whoo so Jerome Priscilla they borrowed a
tent that was broken I think and so they
want the wrong poles they got the wrong
poles so mismatched pieces yep hey at
least we'll all be a little bit warmer
that's true body body heat this is so
cool I've never had a slumber party
inside a tent before I don't remember
when the last time I had a slumber party
you guys ready for our sleepover yeah
I'm excited for the sleepover I haven't
had an adult sleepover ever in my life
cuddle party yeah yeah you got like the
mansion of Ted's right that's your thing
there's not that shift any yeah look at
this all spacious it is four people in
here well I could you maybe one more I
really think we can look there could be
a fifth person laying down like right
over there yeah all right bedtime
bedtime good night good night good night
guys good night what are we doing today
we're going on a cruise
hello I just feel like we're in a hotel
right now all right we are in our room
this is nice
oh [ __ ] ninja dad with the ninja tab